people talk about these life hacks I
mean really what they're talking about
is the 80 20 rule making the income
stream that's the largest even larger a
lot of times is easier than trying to
get the trickles going if you go that
path where you actually do take time to
golf and vacation and do the things you
actually like doing it makes you so much
better as a business person most people
make the mistake of pursuing this goal
of business and wealth at the expense of
everything else you know I think that in
order to develop discipline you have to
practice like pushing yourself to things
you don't want to do
so what are the habits of highly
successful content creators and
entrepreneurs what are some of the keys
when it comes to productivity and time
management to get everything done when
it comes to actually making money
publishing videos juggling family and
life and all of the things and what are
the deeper principles needed so that we
don't end up successful as content
creators but then eventually lose our
soul in the process I'm excited for this
conversation with Ryan Pineda which is
going to be really a wide range of
topics on some things like productivity
and time management but we're going to
be exploring his book The Wealthy way
and learning a little bit about what
he's doing with a mission to help people
not go broke trying to get rich and so
Ryan welcome to the podcast yeah happy
to be here if people are just joining
episode one we talked all about content
you've gotten over 500 million views
probably a lot more by now and 1.5
million followers so definitely check
that out in the think media podcast
show notes as far as the past episode
but I'm excited in this episode to go a
little bit more like inner game mindset
talk a little bit about your book but
let's start off with first of all who
are you in just an even smaller nutshell
and how did this book come about the
wealthy way yeah so the one minute
version of me
um X pro baseball player turned
entrepreneur
um I've got like you said lots of
businesses
um most of them are doing seven eight
figures a year you know I do content
creation and I would say that takes up
most of my time making content
ironically and the businesses are pretty
self-sustaining without me and I'm kind
of the lead engine to them also have a
wife who we're about to celebrate our
10-year anniversary together you know
two kids with a third on the way
um and a guy who has a lot of different
passions in life and I think that's
where the wealthy way comes from of not
just being only focused on you know
making money or growing my brand and so
if somebody asks you for an elevator
pitch of what is the wealthy way a
um what is it you know I should have
like something I've really thought out
and like recited because I don't
um but basically it's just a way of life
that
um I believe everyone should live and I
believe that it leads to you know true
happiness and purpose and fulfillment
um I think that there's a lot of people
on social media teaching you know things
that I just don't agree with on you know
whether it's hustle culture whether it's
you know life doesn't matter or nothing
happens after this whether it's
um you know you gotta sacrifice all
these things in order to you know reach
your goals like I don't necessarily
agree with any of that and so the
wealthy way was a response
um to all of those negative things you
don't want to sacrifice your health you
don't want to sacrifice your kids you
don't want to sacrifice your family on
the path to the world's definition of
success yeah you know it's interesting
because
um as entrepreneurs right most people
start out becoming entrepreneurs broke
that's why they they fall into
entrepreneurship very very few are like
super rich and then they just jump into
entrepreneurs and so you know being
broke it's tough like you have to scrap
and grind and do all those things but
you know eventually if you do figure it
out you then have a new problem you have
this problem of hey well now that I have
money and some success uh I want more of
it and you know don't get me wrong I
want my businesses to grow and be better
and bigger and everything else too but
most people make the mistake of pursuing
this goal of business and wealth and
well their version of wealth
um at the expense of everything else
because you'll get a lot of people who
tell you that's what has to be done for
it to happen hey you want to hit a big
goal you're not gonna be able to spend
time with your kids like you know
they'll understand when they get older
right like you're gonna have to
sacrifice now to hit that goal you know
you'll have people who um they they
don't have time to work out or eat
properly because they they're just busy
working right and so their health
deteriorates and guess what they make
all this money and they can't even enjoy
it they can't even do anything right or
you know they they lose their family
they lose their wife they get divorced
um you know faith is a huge element of
the wealthy way it's like you know as a
Christian faith should be my number one
thing and if I neglect that you know and
I think about man how many hours a week
do I spend with God and In Worship
and then how many hours a week do I
spend in business and you start to
really ask yourself that question you're
like well which one is a priority to me
and so it's really about reframing
people on what's actually important in
life and how you can actually have it
all you don't have to sacrifice any of
these things in fact you can have all of
those things and still have a wildly
successful business it sounds it's an
amazing Vision but for many of us it
probably sounds
um also kind of like overwhelming
because we're like yeah that sounds
amazing but I'm I'm hustling I'm
struggling I'm trying to get it all done
maybe not my Health's not going very
good right now my family's not going
very good right now so I want to get
into some of the tactics you talk about
really in regard to
time management you wrote a chapter that
you don't get more time we all have 24
hours in a day one of the things that
anyone who knows you knows is that you
are incredibly effective with your time
and you bring up a couple powerful
principles the first is the Pareto
Principle which an Italian economist
noticed that 80 of the land in Italy was
owned by 20 of the population and then
started to extrapolate this across like
all industries that a lot of times what
80 percent of the time we spend in our
business only accounts for 20 of the
revenue yeah whereas twenty percent of
our time in our business accounts for
eighty percent of the revenue and this
goes into like roads driven on in a city
yeah 80 you know 20 percent of traffic
or 80 of traffic drives on twenty
percent of the roads and that makes
sense those are the major highways the
back roads there's a lot less traffic
there how has the Pareto Principle been
a key in your life yeah you know the
first time I ever heard about this was
um the four hour work week with Tim
Ferriss and I read that oh man probably
when I was like 20 years old before I
ever had a business or anything but to
me it made sense
um I was like man yeah you should just
focus on the things that produce the
best result for whatever it is you're
trying to do right and I think you can
apply that to all things in business and
life you know in business right it's
very easy to say okay for me what's the
best thing I can do currently in my
business well I can tell you my house
living business exploded when I finally
just decided you know what I'm not going
to run around and manage projects
anymore and go to these construction
sites I'm not going to list the
properties anymore that's just not a
good use of my time and it takes forever
I'm gonna Focus all my time on just
getting deals because that's what brings
in the revenue that's what I'm good at
and I enjoy doing it and so guess what
the moment I hired out a project manager
and I hired out a listing agent these
other guys uh was the moment we
basically like 4xed because I focused on
the thing I wanted to right so that was
a business example but you know in life
people talk about these life hacks I
mean really what they're talking about
is the 80 20 rule they're like hey what
are some things I can do they give me
big results that aren't like that crazy
to do right and so
um there's lots of people who have
different life hacks but you know like
uh a great book I read was Atomic habits
and it just talks about like your
surroundings and so like when I think
about a life hack I'm like yeah if I
want to be healthier just get rid of all
of the snacks in my house and like
that's a great way for me to you know
not eat bad and that's just like doing
things like that affect you big time
some of the questions that you wrote in
here and this of course can apply to us
as content creators business owners you
can apply it to every area of life but
you said what are the most important
projects for me now considering my
values and goals which products account
for the majority of my sales and so we
could also look you know maybe we have
an online course we've created we do
affiliate marketing maybe we have brand
deals maybe we have ad Revenue but which
one is actually generating the most and
a lot of times if we double down on the
income stream making the income stream
that's the largest even larger a lot of
times is easier than trying to get at
the trickles going more have you found
that yeah you know we talked about this
on the first podcast about AdSense and
sponsors and you're like do you do any
of that and I'm like no I'm like I don't
I don't worry about it at all right and
I know you and I have had the
conversation you're like dude you could
make seven figures a year from sponsors
if like you really built it out and took
it serious and all this you know even
going back to it's like yeah we could
but it's gonna take away from all this
other stuff and it would definitely be
an 80 20 because we make more than 10
million dollars so it's like a million
to 10 million is 10 right but it's going
to take so much to build it out when we
could just try and take say the 10
million to 20. that makes sense and it
would go to to be clear for some
listening though their business model is
AD revenue and yeah deals because if
you're a pure content creator you don't
have a flipping business you don't have
a coaching business nevertheless you
could still then still figure out which
of these income flows another question
I'm leveraging my strengths am I
leveraging my strengths and what I'm
doing or can this be delegated you
figure that out okay be better better to
have someone else list better to have
someone else manage do you still pick
the deals out today no so I basically I
don't do anything in a house living
business anymore got it so you little by
little have delegated and hired people
in even areas of your strengths I would
argue because you were good at that so
you've you delegated weaknesses first
but then you've even delegated strengths
yeah I mean because you start now
looking at opportunity costs and like
what is the highest and best use of my
time and so as you get new skills and
New Opportunities you gotta really
figure out hey what what's good for me
and like for me at this point I look at
activities that have high leverage where
like I can do them once and they just
make me money a lot like create an
online course create a course right
record it once but you can keep selling
it keep selling it right create a new
business
um you know hire somebody like a key
hire like I'm in charge of that
sometimes like if I hire the right
person once they're going to hire
everyone else and like that's a huge
return massive yeah that's what that's
one of the probably most profound things
that has impacted me in the last year
was when you spoke at growth video live
and we were backstage and you said I
hire top down yeah and so for those that
are at that more advanced level what
does that mean yeah you know most people
try to hire from the bottom up and so if
you have a business you'll be like oh
well I need an admin I need a sales guy
I need a marketing person I need this
person and to me that's the wrong
approach because you're still the person
running the company You're Still The One
having to make these five hires what I
do before I start any company is I hire
the top guy the COO and I'm like hey you
know I need to find this right person
because I'm expecting them to hire all
these other people for me and I only
want to talk to one person right let me
talk to that person and make sure
they're doing what they're supposed to
do how do you find top tier Talent it's
tough man I mean we could go into a
whole podcast on hiring people but you
know obviously just like anything you
gotta Market properly so what pool are
you marketing to are you just posting on
LinkedIn and all that stuff are you
posting on your own social are you
getting referrals like how am I like
getting the pool of talent the next
thing is okay how do I make them an
offer that's you know worthy of their
talent right because top 10 top talent
don't want to work for nothing yeah
right and top talent also wants to see
growth like the naturally talented
people are motivated for growth and so I
always want to performance-based
composition performance-based
compensation but also what can this lead
to down the road right like is this
going to be your only career with me or
are there other things we can do
together amazing
um one of the another questions you were
asking these were kind of all through
the 80 20 framework a little bit what
time of day am I most productive I would
probably say there's 20 of your day
produces 80 of the productivity oh yeah
and then this one's a powerful question
what are the 20 of activities that are
creating 80 of my distraction what do
you mean by that yeah I mean like for a
lot of people you might be on social
media you know and maybe you do 10
different things a day right you're like
okay you know I I go to work I hang out
with my kids I I'm on social media I'm
you know doing XYZ right and when you
really look at it you're like wow like I
get distracted the most from social
media I get distracted working at home
with my kids yeah that's a common thing
it's like all right well you probably
shouldn't work from home like go go out
to a Starbucks go get an executive
suites all right well you know you
shouldn't be on social media if you just
catch yourself there for two hours just
scrolling yeah so we're talking about
you know Habits of Highly Successful
content creators you start killing
distractions figuring out your Peak
productivity starting to leverage your
strengths delegate your weakness focus
on the right products the right projects
and I also like that you said what
activities in my personal life produce
the most happiness I know for me there's
not a lot of time when I sit down and
reverse engineer my week and think
how can I structure my week to be
happier but there are certain times when
I know that uh it's just a dark
reference but The Shining where Jack
Nicholson was writing all work no play
makes Jack a sad boy and then he murders
his family so that's not you don't want
to push yourself that far like that was
too far in the movie The Shining yeah um
but it's it is funny because lack of
margin if you have if if your calendar
is void of the things that bring you
happiness I know when I start going to
just kind of a more discouraged or
depressed place it's because I pack my
calendar so full that I'm not running
out walking getting fresh air having
margin to spend time with my family
having just literally the word margin
yeah a little bit of margin goes a long
way in terms of my happiness so if I
overcrowd my calendar The Joy gets
sucked out of almost my entire calendar
yeah and we talk about the concept of
margin in the book and like you know at
the end of the day I one thousand
percent agree and that's you know wealth
is an acronym so L stands for lifestyle
and that's exactly what we're talking
about the things that you just enjoy
doing right they may not bring a
financial return or anything but like
they bring you happiness and fulfillment
so like for me you know I golf a lot and
it brings me fulfillment right I like to
work out I mean that is health related
but I I just it brings me fulfillment
working out you know we just got back
from the Dominican I like to Vacation a
lot it brings me fulfillment and guess
here's my thing with the wealthy way and
just compared to the other method I
believe just based on my own growth that
if you go that path where you actually
do take time to golf and vacation and do
the things you actually like doing it
makes you so much better as a business
person I get inspired for new ideas when
I'm on vacation I meet people when I
golf I am relaxed I'm not stressed and
then when I do show up to work I'm ready
to roll like I'm a hundred percent I'm
crushing it whereas other people who
just get stuck in ground Hogs day you
know they're working at fifty percent
you know efficiency and for some it
might be hard because some people might
think they're not at a place that
they've reached Financial Freedom and
nevertheless and the truth is a wealthy
way you you go into I skip past kind of
like your get money now like you started
couch flipping yeah like you can find
you start getting money you start
leveraging it you start but
there are some people listening to this
and I can even relate to this you also
you start having finances is not your
biggest problem that's not my biggest
problem my biggest problem actually is
health I'm trying to get my workout
Health game going and I'm trying to look
through a framework of realizing that a
lot of what is happening in my life is
self-inflicted yeah meaning and there's
entrepreneurs out there you meet them
all the time right their Groundhog's Day
is their own fault they probably also
can't fix it in 24 hours but they could
probably fix it in six to 12 months if
they just started making different
decisions not prioritizing money but
prioritizing family vacation scheduling
those things being intentional to put
different things on their calendar you
you shared another one here that is a
powerful time management principle which
is Parkinson's law and there was a um
it basically is
or you define it but isn't it isn't it
the however much time you schedule for
work is It's Gonna Fill it so if you say
I'm gonna I have 40 hours for the
project it's gonna take 40 hours yeah
but if you say I have four hours for the
project it's gonna take four hours yep
100 and I think that that law is more
profound that many people don't know I
mean a lot of people have heard of the
80 20 rule but very few have heard of
Parkinson's law and it's true I mean the
reason I'm able to accomplish a lot each
week is because I say hey this is the
only amount of time I have to do this
right most entrepreneurs they'll be like
oh well you know I've got the whole day
to get it done and so it takes the whole
day whereas I'm like no I've got two
hours to get this done and then I'm
gonna go golf yeah and so I do get it
done in two hours it's good and I still
get to golf right and so I mean most
people like I say when they say they
work 70 hour weeks they're not really
working 70 hours very few are they're
they might be working 30 35. the other
half is spent probably on social media
probably just being inefficient probably
just sitting there with like a dead
stare at the wall not doing anything
like it nobody can focus for 70 80 hours
yeah so Parkinson's law basically stops
that from happening right because you
just give yourself a deadline like we
all do things like on a deadline uh one
example is you know back when you were
in school if you're a good student like
or a decent student anytime you get a
project or a homework whatever it is
like you do it the night before that's
what most people do right right so if
they tell you you got a week you're
doing it you know day six but if they
tell you you got a pop quiz tomorrow if
you're a good student you're gonna do it
that night it's been something that
we've always done and it's good like
people operate better when their backs
against the wall and they they put
pressure on themselves are you ready to
start or grow your YouTube channel do
you feel stuck and need help connecting
the dots join this free web class where
you'll learn the step-by-step playbook
for YouTube success we've helped
thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs just like you grow their
influence with video register today for
this exclusive training at
thinkmasterclass.com yeah so having that
deadline and so the case study was
Microsoft Japan in 2019 implemented a
four day work week and so that's 20
percent less timed for people to
complete their work but their
productivity actually increased 40
percent and so constraints having
deadlines people are actually more
productive you want to know what's
another good example of that and I I've
never heard anyone use this as a case
study but I mean look at Chick-fil-A I
mean they're not open on Sundays like
they choose to be a six you know day a
week business and I'm sure they have
their own Revenue goals and everything
else that they want to hit but they're
dominating but they get it done in six
days yeah that's pretty powerful it's a
wealthy way principle too because
they're truly actually honoring the
Sabbath yep so they're seeing God's
Supernatural power in their business
because of it that Sunday would be such
a lucrative day for them oh dude because
I would go there after church they would
get everybody after church yeah so they
also they I mean obviously they're aware
that they're leaving money on the table
Yeah I think that's a good principle
that I can learn from too because but
but my philosophy is I don't think
they're leaving money on the table Yeah
I think by doing that they're actually
maximizing what they became sure I think
by doing it not you know they're leaving
Sunday Revenue out they have to at least
accept the fact that obviously yeah
after church well but but I guess it
comes down to would they have gotten
there and which is what I'm saying I
think they maximize their outcome taking
you know God's blessing thing out of it
okay you know like I think just for me
like I haven't worked weekends in years
yeah right so I'm leaving money on the
table by not working weekends I could
totally be filming videos and closing
deals and whatever right so I leave
money on the table but guess what I
think if I were to just take that
lifestyle for five years you know take
take me back five years and you know you
you reverse you know what happened not
working weekends what would have
happened had I worked weekends and burnt
out yeah and gone through all these ups
and downs yeah and maybe maybe even
there was short term maybe more money
but who even knows I I just I would bet
I'm not where I'm at today I would think
I'm in a lesser Place well that's that's
a powerful Insight question for you do
you
does your team work five days a week
yeah our office isn't open on the
weekends not on the weekends but why
don't you do uh Microsoft Japan's
four-day work I mean to be honest I do
the four day work week right now because
I golf every Friday yeah from what I've
been seeing I think they're kind of
transitioning to the four day work week
because like they'll be having like
lunch parties and stuff every Friday
like I'm never involved and then like
the the Fridays I have gone there I'm
like dude where's everyone at like I I'm
starting to think they think Fridays are
optional too okay but no I mean
truthfully and this is the truth of the
matter even with the wealthy way and
everything it's like you know what is
work right like work is a hard thing to
describe for me like what I consider
work is like when I have to be at some
place at some time to do some thing you
know right now I gotta film and then I
gotta go back and I gotta do this so
like that that's how I Define work um
for business now am I always thinking
about business and new ideas and
everything like outside of work yeah
like I'm my mind is always going and
Racing for the entrepreneur a good point
like you doing golf is huge your brain's
untangling things yeah like I'm thinking
about things and so like I am working
and you know that's hard for the
listener yeah seven people just got
offended yeah they're like oh Ryan's
working on the golf course but for the
entrepreneurs founder starter yeah yeah
for sure yeah you're brainstorming
that's why I'm I'm a big proponent of
vacations because it gives you time away
from the business to think about the
business yeah you know and so you know
and do I text my employees and stuff and
do some of them work on the weekends on
their own time sure they can everyone
can do whatever they want like you
basically I make everyone live by
Parkinson's law that's basically what I
do I'm like look you don't have to come
in on the weekend but this is what you
need to get done yeah and if you don't
get it done then you figure it out on
your own time outputs yeah we're trying
to do that you know a lot of our team is
remote only a small percentage now is in
Vegas everybody else is remote we split
our time between Seattle and Vegas now
so even we aren't going to be
championing the local culture so we've
accepted I think media that you have a
lot of people here you know when we went
to Miami to tour pbd's Place everybody
moves to Fort Lauderdale playing
everyone's in-house everyone's there and
you know I was tooling through things in
my own brain but realized based on
family and our values of getting our
kids around their parents in Seattle
we're like okay we're going to be more
remote and I know for many people
listening that is really the model
especially because some a small
percentage may have some kind of a local
thing but chances are va's even overseas
people you're working with you got to
figure out time management and people
management remote
outputs is a key that you got to measure
on yes potentially Time and Time
tracking but at the end of the day isn't
it about I pay you to accomplish a
certain a certain task yeah is that
accomplished task accomplished or not
right and so really powerful so we've
we've been talking about Habits of
Highly Successful content creators
really this time management piece
pareto's principle that's the 80 20 rule
Parkinson's law and really just some
powerful questions people can ask to get
control of their schedule to ultimately
be more disciplined and to be more
effective when it comes to content
creation and I highly recommend of
course checking out the book we'll link
it up in the show notes 99 Cents 99
Cents and over 700 positive reviews uh
it's cool to see congratulations on
launching the book I know you got
another one in the works but I
definitely uh recommend uh people check
it out I want to ask you this so you're
outspoken as a Christian in business
um has there been any pushback
since you've been being outspoken about
your faith maybe from the algorithms
maybe not getting as many views on
certain things
um which is fine I don't really care but
no I think it's been overwhelming very
positive I think at the end of the day
uh no matter what your business is right
um we we're going to provide a service
of you know I have a tax firm I have
househipping I have you know media like
we're gonna provide you a service but no
there's other people who provide that
same service right so at the end of the
day most people are going to work with
you based on you know values and can
they relate to you and so you know if
you ever looked at our coaching programs
we have a lot of Christians and a lot of
them say they're like look the only
reason I chose you over this is because
of the faith element so do you lose
people sure but it goes back to you know
which option ends up being better in
five years yeah and and that's taking
you know it even if financially it
wasn't the right choice spiritually you
know it was and so there will be you
know some riches in heaven to pay way
more than that what advice do you have
for Christian business owners and
content creators and of course a
listener no matter what their faith
background could be applying this advice
to their core values and their beliefs
but what specific advice do you have for
Christian business owners and content
creators yeah I mean at the end of the
day right
um your morals should resonate through
the company you know like we have our
four core values and they're really
Christian based you know the core value
number one is serve others that's
Christian based uh core value number two
is trained daily like get better every
day try to grow
um core value number three is play fair
have integrity right core value number
five uh four is no ego right don't have
pride like you know so even though not
everyone who worked for us is Christian
um they gotta have Christian values yeah
and you know if they don't they can't
work for us it is what it is right and
so
um I think make sure that your values
permeate through your company but also
you need to be the best example of those
values because nobody's following you if
you say hey follow these things and then
you don't do them what routines support
your personal productivity you know I'm
a big proponent of morning routine uh we
talk about that in the book as well I've
been doing a morning routine for about
seven years now and it's adjusted as
time has gone on but I mean currently my
morning routine is I wake up at five
o'clock I jump in the shower what time
did you go to bed uh usually around 10
10 11. BET at 10 you wake up at five
here's the morning routine yep so then
you know from about 5 30 to 6 30 I'm
gonna spend my time with God because if
I'm gonna say that faith is the most
important thing to me then I should
probably do it the first thing I do kids
and wife are still asleep yeah
everyone's asleep
um so from you know 5 30 6 30 that's
what I do 6 30 7 30 I go to the gym I
get a gym in my house now so walk
downstairs crank it out for an hour then
7 30 I have options like basically my
morning routine is done I've been trying
to get better at golf like I've been
saying so I'll usually go practice golf
for like an hour and so maybe it's at
the course or whatever or get that done
and then you know that's like 8 30 and
then I go get ready and head to the
office around nine to ten sometime and
then roll through basically more or less
a nine to five schedule for uh days a
week because Friday is then going to be
your proper 8 holes my proper 18 holes I
gotta get at least one 18 holes a week
but yeah that that that's basically how
every morning is like that
um but
you know with business and everything
else it all fluctuates as a younger
entrepreneur when you're was there
something that you did that hurt your
productivity that you've given up in the
last five to ten years there's something
that hurt my productivity yeah like you
no longer do in regards to maybe how you
spend your time or your energy or your
schedule or just anything because it
seems like today
you're at like a near perfect level of
discipline of efficiency I mean I mean
it's and I mean like with empathy for
The Listener too like it is it is fun
like someone like you I the message I'm
trying to get across is like your life
was built it didn't just appear out of
nowhere yeah yeah and
um I I mean as an athlete professional
baseball and all that like you don't get
there without a level of discipline and
whatnot so that seems you know we could
we don't have time to go into like your
childhood or whatever but I'm just
wondering if there's been a lessons
specifically we're like yeah when I gave
that up or something that changed in my
diet or something that like just as I've
made adjustments I've well you know like
like right now I'm in the middle of a
five-day fast and so that's water only I
used to never fast yeah and that's like
a new thing for me within the last year
and a half and I mean that's been
life-changing doing that and you know
obviously fasting takes incredible
amounts of discipline and you know I
think that in order to develop
discipline you have to practice like
pushing yourself to things you don't
want to do right so it's like I'll
switch up my schedule and be like you
know what I'm gonna start waking up at
four just because you know for no reason
other than I need to test myself and
push myself further I'll get a new
strength coach I'll go and try a new
diet I try new diets all the time just
like to switch it up
um and experience new things so I think
you you got to get out of your comfort
zone that's number one I think the
second thing that really propelled me
was I stopped
um wasting time on like things that
weren't doing anything for me so you
know it it might be easy to say like now
like oh well you Golf and you do all
sort of stuff but like when I look at
like the game of golf and what it does
for me I'm like all right well I golf
with you know business people and we we
do deals on the course I get exercise
out of it and I stay active now that I
don't play baseball I gotta like compete
in something to fill that urge in me to
compete you know pickleballs becoming a
competition thing now but like golf has
all these benefits so I'm like it is
doing a lot for me I'm not just like
wasting totally right
um whereas okay for a lot of people's
social media you know you're just
sitting there for like two hours just
scrolling do a nut like that's not doing
anything for you right
um you know if you're just watching
Netflix and stuff I got nothing against
Netflix like I'll watch it you know
occasionally with my wife and stuff but
like you know there are people who are
obsessed with it like yeah you're not
really a show guy yeah watch much like
one thing I really gave up too was
watching sports like I used to watch
every Lakers game I used to watch a lot
of time yeah every Packers game game you
know now the Raiders people like dude
are you gonna get season tickets to the
knights to the Raiders you know the A's
are coming to town you're getting season
tickets yeah I'm like bro I don't have
time to watch all these games like
I'm busy like doing stuff I was hoping
you were gonna get like box seats or
something so you could start taking your
team and and invite think media no no
but you know I we'll we'll get we'll go
to like a game yeah I just don't need uh
season tickets yeah yeah for real that's
true because then then you have to serve
the tickets do the tickets serve you or
do you serve the tickets because you're
constantly there that's uh those are
powerful do you have um a Life Bible
verse or a favorite Bible character man
there's a lot of great characters in in
verses and everything too
um I think Proverbs three five and six
is amazing you know uh what's it say man
now you're putting me on the spot
um
basically it's you know let God direct
your path you know man now now you're
you're getting me on the spot but
transcends all understanding uh trust in
the Lord with all your heart and lean
not on your own understanding in all
your ways submit to him and he will make
your pass straight straight exactly you
know that's really good uh especially
for us as entrepreneurs we want to make
our own paths and it's like no I think
we should probably just let you know God
make her pass how about a character that
you really resonate with
um character I really like Paul's life
you know my son is named James Paul so
you know we love the Book of James
um and then just watching what Paul did
um was pretty incredible so you know to
see a guy who was like literally uh
persecuting Christians to come to Faith
and then write the majority of the New
Testament you're like wow this is crazy
but you know like a verse that's been
really sticking with me lately
um is in Matthew and you know it says
that let your light shine before others
so that they may glorify your father in
Heaven as I've grown in influence in
social media I've really started to
think about that of like man you know
how do I like let my light shine more
and really show people like how great
God is and
you know before I used to be like oh
well this was before social media I'm
like dude I don't want to like brag and
like be out there and all the stuff but
it's like man you can really inspire
people and bring people to Jesus if they
just hear your message yeah and hear how
great you know he's made your life yeah
like you should be shouting that
everywhere yeah you know think about the
Bible like the Bible is content that
these guys are sharing how great their
lives are after meeting Jesus and you're
just like why am I not doing that yeah I
think I think to
we are all have different levels of
skills and talents and abilities and
influence and Gifts of the way that God
has gifted us and I I think there's no
doubt that some I know Christians can
get kind of judgy and they could be kind
of judgy about your style because you're
very successful businessman yeah very
successful entrepreneur but for my take
you also are able to influence people
that a lot of other people aren't able
to influence and you're at just we all
have different spheres of society and uh
your from your sphere of society I I
mean that's just to even acknowledge
that and acknowledge you that at the end
of the day from your platform you're
giving glory to God you're an unashamed
uh follower of Jesus and you're
incredibly effective at business and
content and social media so you're you
are letting your light shine uh that
people would praise the Father in heaven
and
um I think I mean bottom line I think
that sometimes though it can make people
unsecure you know when they when they
see somebody with a level of success
like yours when hopefully you even talk
about Envy in the book when hopefully
it's like it's way more about
collaboration and uh you know the
ability to learn from you know others
and uh and promote diversity of
expression in the body of Christ yeah
100 as we land the plane I want to just
hear a little bit of a vision about this
wealthy Kingdom project you have of
course the book is out we'll link all
this stuff up in the show notes but I
specifically you could tell us a little
bit about it but you have a vision
for people to start specifically
entrepreneurs to start their own Bible
studies so after an episode like this
you know for some they could take away
some of the time management and
productivity habits we definitely have a
lot of Christians in our community and
so if you made it this far in the
podcast this specific thing would be
cool they could be a part of your thing
or they could just take action talk a
little bit about the vision of this
project called The Wealthy Kingdom the
book's the wealthy way you have like the
wealthy investor the wealthy Creator
yeah all these different projects but uh
what is the vision with this and what
are you hoping to see with these Bible
studies yeah so you know I've had a
Bible study for the last five years that
I've hosted out of my home and at my
office and a lot of my employees go and
you know different entrepreneurs go and
I mean you've been there you've seen it
like we've had so many people have their
lives changed like marriage is restored
people giving their life to Christ
um so many great things from it and I
just never realized that it was kind of
unique what we had or have yeah um
there's just not a lot of places like
that especially locally right and God
put it on my heart
um and towards the end of last year when
he's like dude you need to do this
everywhere and I was like oh man okay
like I don't know how we're gonna do it
but we'll we'll figure it out and you
know just the ideas and everything
started to form and you know sure enough
we just launched it actually today May
1st um wealthy Kingdom and you know it's
gonna be my most fulfilling thing that I
do I don't know that it makes any sense
financially but it's like I'm gonna give
it everything I've got to grow it and so
basically what it is is
um a community for Christian
entrepreneurs so you know worldwide we
have people already in different parts
of the world who are in it and you know
we do calls every week
um virtually that people can attend
we're going to be running
um Retreats you know men's Retreats
women's Retreats couples Retreats you
know big events uh mission trips all
these things
um but you know one of the things I'm
most excited about is we're going to
launch local Bible studies Nationwide
and worldwide I guess that anyone can
partake in and so we're really trying to
build leaders in wealthy Kingdom who are
willing to go out and start their own
Bible studies in their local areas and
just bring people in other entrepreneurs
and business people and we're going to
give them the curriculum the training
and everything so everyone Nationwide
will be on the same you know curriculum
for that you know 48 week period and
um I think that we're gonna change
communities locally I think we're going
to get a lot of people who maybe aren't
into church you know and so maybe they
fell away from church they got church
hurt or they've never been to church and
it's intimidating but they'll definitely
come to this and then I think coming to
this we'll get them back into church
totally so I'm excited for it man I love
the vision and you know this the wealthy
way it kind of reminds me of one of my
favorite verses and I think three John
the third book of John right where it
says beloved I pray that you'd prosper
and be in health even as your soul
prospers your definition of wealth I
would think is a lot bigger than money
it's this idea of the impact you make in
your life marriage family kids uh health
and uh man it's just incredibly
inspiring what you're doing and just
want to acknowledge you and thank you
for pouring into our community and uh
encourage of course listeners to check
out the show notes with all the
resources but also to you know question
of the day what has this inspired you to
do next you know do you should you be
launching a Bible study how can you dial
in your calendar but how can you even
maybe take the content that you're
creating to a level deeper level of
purpose
um super inspired by how you've been
doing that Ryan thanks for coming on
yeah appreciate you man all you're doing